[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Hi.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And today we're going to explore
how Google Cloud's Data Lake
solution allows
enterprises to securely
ingest, store,
process, and analyze
any volume or type of data.
For example, a financial
services company
might be getting an influx
of loan applications.
It's important to accelerate
the time to process and approve
the loans using machine
learning in order
to get the money to the right
businesses and people faster.
Let's walk through how
a data engineer and data
scientist can work together
on the solution using
Cloud Storage and Dataproc.
Dataproc is a fully managed
service allowing enterprises
to run Apache Spark
and Apache Hadoop
clusters with
30-plus open source
components in a simple,
secure, and cost-efficient way.
In the first step
of the pipeline,
the data engineer will
run Spark jobs on Dataproc
to convert the loan data from
CSV tables into Hive tables.
The metadata for
the Hive tables will
be saved in a new fully managed
Dataproc Metastore service.
This allows for easy discovery
and governance of your data.
You can now easily create a
Dataproc Metastore service
from the Dataproc UI and
start using it across clusters
by sharing the service endpoint.
In Spark, it requires just
three additional lines of code
to connect to Dataproc Metastore
and enable Hive table support.
To run the Spark
job, we now support
running Dataproc on
Google Kubernetes Engine.
It's simple to set
up by just including
one additional line
of code to create
a Dataproc on GKE cluster.
Spark jobs will now run on
Kubernetes instead of YARN.
This reduces code
dependencies and allows
you to better utilize idle
cloud or on prem resources.
The data engineer can
then run the Spark job
on the Google Kubernetes
engine cluster
to convert the CSV
data to Hive tables.
And data scientists can
now begin their analysis
of the loan data
in the Hive table
by connecting to the shared
Dataproc Metastore service.
To create the machine
learning features and model,
we'll use Jupyter notebooks,
a popular data science tool.
We've made it easy to use
Jupyter notebooks and Apache
Spark together
with Dataproc hub.
NVIDIA GPUs can be added
to the Dataproc cluster
along with installing
of the rapids, which
includes XGBoost to be
used in Jupyter notebooks
to create the model.
And using GPUs instead of
CPUs can improve training time
by over 40x.
Let's see how you can
use these features.
Start from the
Dataproc notebooks
UI where you can now create a
Dataproc hub instance, which
makes it easier to
use and manage Jupyter
notebooks for large teams.
Admins can manage and control
what cluster configurations can
be used by users, allowing
for improved resource and cost
management.
You can then use
a PySpark notebook
to create your XGBoost model.
First, read the data using GPUs.
Next, train a
classification model
to predict loan approvals,
also using GPUs.
Then evaluate the model
with 1 being accepted
and 0 being denied.
The model can then be saved
to Google Cloud Storage
and is easily loaded to be
used again in other Spark jobs.
The model is now ready
to be used in production
to do batch loan approvals
on new data lending and Hive
tables.
In this demo, we showed how
a financial service company
can create a model to accelerate
loan processing time using
Spark on Dataproc running
on Kubernetes, Jupyter
notebooks, and NVIDIA
Rapids and GPUs,
all while storing the Hive
metadata in Dataproc Metastore.
Head on over to these
links to learn more and get
started with building your data
lake on Google Cloud today.